[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'en souviens très bien c'était un
dimanche de janvier 2016 on était une
bonne centaine à 6 dans cette salle on
regarder dans la même direction
je buvais les paroles des différents
intervenants
j'ai ri j'ai pleuré
finalement c'est ce que j'aime dans le
cinéma c'est vivre des émotions ce qui
est plus étonnant c'est que ce n'était
pas le dernier film de xavier dolan ou
encore d' inarritu que j'apprécie tant
j'étais en train de regarder un film
documentaire et ce film documentaire
c'est demain un film de mélanie laurent
et cyril dion
ce film est rentré au panthéon des films
documentaires les plus vues de
l'histoire et le bout public suisse
avait d'ailleurs contribué à ce succès
on peut se poser la question pourquoi ce
film alors qu'elle a beaucoup d'autres
du genre a marqué les esprits pourquoi
est ce qu'il m'a inspiré moi qui n'étais
pas particulièrement converti à la
problématique du développement durable
bonne question
une chose est sûre c'est que ce n'est
pas ce film qui a attiré notre attention
sur la problématique du développement
durable jamais et la tension n'a été
aussi forte sur ces problématiques ces
derniers mois voire ces dernières années
j'en veux pour preuve les nombreuses
manifestations populaires qu'on a vu
émerger la marche pour le climat les
grèves étudiantes du vendredi est
évidemment la grève des femmes toutes
ces manifestations milite pour un
développement plus inclusif à ses
nombreuses manifestations vient
s'ajouter à un nombre incalculable
d'émissions de télévision d'articles de
presse et une avalanche d'intervention
sur les réseaux sociaux
7 / communication crée une forme de
pression sociale
alors heureusement pendant ses nombreux
événements il ya rarement de violences
physiques
en revanche on on retrouve une certaine
violence dans les mots probablement pour
pousser à réfléchir essayer d'influencer
les opinions publiques les politiques de
l'urgence de la situation
j'adorerais vous dire ce soir qu'il n'y
a pas d'urgence
malheureusement elle est bien réelle
c'est
sur communication dont je vous parlais
forme une forme de diktat de ce qui est
bon de faire mais ce qui n'est pas bon
de faire à tel point qu'aujourd'hui
probablement que comme moi lorsque vous
allez faire vos courses vous sentez
responsable ou du moins coupable si vous
n'achetez pas les tomates bio vous
sentez coupable si vous prenez la
voiture alors que vous pourriez prendre
les transports publics
le choix des bons comportements devient
complexe
alors je vous rassure je suis pas là
pour vous mettre une pression
supplémentaire ce soir mais il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui cette pression est quasi
manichéenne
c'est juste c'est faux c'est blanc c'est
noir comme une sorte de religion à
laquelle nous devons tous adhéré on est
partisan ou on ne l'est pas
alors posons nous les bonnes questions
comment se comporter dans des contextes
relativement complexes comme ceux ci
première chose il faut accepter que nous
avons tous des comportements
contradictoires
vous en avez j'en ai personne n'est
irréprochable
si on veut avancer trouver des solutions
on doit accepter si on voulait être 100%
irréprochable probablement qu'on ne
serait pas là ce soir
simplement pour limiter l'impact en
terme de déplacement d'une telle
audience est probablement qu'on ferait
pas d'enfant parce que ceux qui ont nom
réalise probablement à quel point c'est
difficile de limiter ces déchets je vais
essayer de vous donner une couleur un
peu plus optimistes ce soir en vous
partageant cette belle expérience qu'on
a vécu avec avec mon équipe
donner un discours plus heureux en effet
nous avons décidé une petite équipe et
moi de réaliser une version plus local
de demain un film qu'on a simplement
appelé demain genève
on a organisé une campagne de
financement participative qui a été un
des plus grands succès en suisse et en
suisse romande une saine pression qui
nous a montré à quel point la thématique
le calme en était très forte
toujours plus forte on avait
complètement sous-estimé le nombre de
sollicitations qu'on allait recevoir des
centaines des milliers de messages des
gens qui ont annoncé travailler sur des
différentes initiatives
on a passé une année sur les routes de
la région pour rencontrer ces hommes ces
femmes ces gens comme vous comme moi
qui ont décidé d'essayer trouver des
solutions à nos défis environnementaux
sociétaux et économiques
c'était passionnant
à sa sortie le film est rentré dans le
top ten du box office alors qu'il n'est
diffusé que dans un seul canton dans une
seule salle une certaine fierté
quelque part mais surtout un signe fort
les gens se sentent concernés par ce qui
se passe à côté de chez eux
et en ce sens vous moi avons tous un
rôle à jouer alors de cette belle
expérience de film peut tirer un certain
nombre l'apprentissage que je vais vous
faire je me faire un plaisir de vous
partager avec vous ce soir
première chose à bord d une
problématique de manière optimiste en
présentant des solutions plutôt qu'en
essayant de vous reprocher au
comportement est beaucoup plus audible
elle donne envie pour pousser pour
convaincre il faut montrer que les
solutions existent elles soit accessible
il faut montrer l'exemple
gandhi disait montrer l'exemple n'est
pas la meilleure manière de convaincre
c'est la seule tout est dit autre
apprentissage important et je suis
convaincu que les solutions qui sont
proposées ne doivent pas impliquer des
changements fondamentaux dans nos
comportements
on doit développer avancé pape l'homme
par nature n'aime pas le changement
et vous l'avez probablement tous vécu ne
serait-ce que son collègue qui doit
changer de place dans le même bureau
peut sentir un petit peu perturbé
imaginez lorsqu'on touche des
problématiques de société
tous ces services doivent être une
commodité de notes faciles à consommer
toute complexité et quelque part un
frein à son développement
et ça c'est extrêmement important on l'a
fait aussi des belles découvertes et
j'ai le plaisir de vous apprendre pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas qu'il
existe une solution à quasi toute fin
une alternative à quasiment tous les
produits et services
une forme de services durables et pour
ça je vais les illustrer vous pouvez
déjà respecter enfin consommer des
fruits et légumes en respectant la
nature
en choisissant le bio mais vous pouvez
aller plus loin vous pouvez favoriser
les circuits courts en allant
directement chez le producteur
comme à la ferme de budé juste à côté
vous pouvez aussi souscrire à des
commandes de paniers livrables
directement livré chez vous vous assurer
que les différentes personnes impliquées
touche le juste salaire en matière
d'habitat et pour ceux qui cherchent un
appartement à genève font bien conscient
il existe des habitats ou juste loyer
pour ça il suffit de souscrire à une
coopérative d'habitation comme celle d'
équilibre que vous voyez derrière moi et
des coopératives d'habitation
il y en a de plus en plus qui
fleurissent et c'est une bonne nouvelle
en matière de consommation et de
production d'énergie avant réservé aux
propriétaires de maison vous pouvez
aujourd'hui que vous soyez propriétaire
locataire souscrire à l'achat mutualisé
de panneaux solaires sur les toits de
collectivités et donc bénéficier de
cette production pour vous
et en terme de consommation il existe
une monnaie locale durable qui favorise
les circuits courts
cette belle économie circulaire dont
nous profiterons tout ce que je vous
présente ici je vous ai dit il faut
montrer que ça existe faut montrer que
c'est accessible vous montrer l'exemple
il existe même des banques qui prêtent
way qui prête pour autant que vous
répond vous répondiez à un certain
nombre de critères durables et en
matière d'éducation
personnellement une de mes plus belles
découvertes
il existe des crèches en forêt dans
lesquels vous pouvez déposer vos enfants
qui passeront toute l'année quelle que
soit la météo
dehors en contact avec la nature
n'ayez pas peur bien équipé ses enfants
vivent très bien les mauvaise météo
souvent d'ailleurs mieux que leurs
éducateurs
et puis si toutes ces solutions ne vous
parle pas vous avez pour la plupart
d'entre vous probablement déjà la chance
de disposer d'un des plus beaux outils
qui nous était donné le droit de vote
voilà une belle manière d'avoir un
impact un impact fort sur des décisions
locales qui compte
laissez moi aussi insisté sur une
observation forte
toutes les solutions que nous avons
rencontrés ou du moins la plupart ne
sont pas portés par les politiques qui
souvent d'ailleurs ont souvent un temps
de retard parce qu'elles se font l'écho
de tendance est malheureusement assez
rarement porteurs d'initiatives la
majorité des initiatives qu on la
rencontre était portée insufflé par des
citoyens comme vous comme moi qui ont
décidé de trouver des solutions pour
répondre à des problématiques autrement
souvent
animé par une quête de sens quête de
sens inter et ces personnes qui nous
disent qu'il n'est pas trop tard mais
qu'il faut se bouger vous moi avons un
rôle important à jouer dans cette
transition
vous l'aurez compris cette expérience de
film a été une magnifique expérience
j'en suis d'ailleurs encore encore très
ému on a fait des magnifiques rencontres
de ces personnes passionnantes
souvent parce qu'elles sont passionnés
donc laissez moi partir en vous donnant
trois conseils en matière de
consommation puisque c'est souvent ça
qui est complexe savoir quels sont les
bons comportements de consommation
première chose favoriser les actions qui
ont un impact plutôt que le nombre
d'actions ce critère d'impact devient
capitale il ya d'ailleurs des nouveaux
modèles de qualification de
quantification développement durable qui
se base sur cet indicateur qui est
l'impact
donc si on revient problématiques de
consommation journalière
le critère qui a le plus d'impact c'est
la proximité puisque systémiquement
cette proximité va permettre d'enrichir
des acteurs locaux limiter les
déplacements et donc la production de
co2 ces différentes parties prenantes
vaut rien investir localement un
magnifique exemple un peu simplifié joue
la corde d'économie circulaire
deuxième conseil concentrez-vous sur des
actions qui vous concernent des domaines
qui vous concerne vous ne serez jamais
meilleur que quand vous êtes directement
concernés par l'impact de vos propres
actions et troisième conseil probante
plus important et là je prends ma
posture d'entrepreneurs favoriser les
actions collectives
je suis un fervent défenseur de
l'intelligence collective
on est plusieurs on est plus forts à
plusieurs on est plus intelligent à
plusieurs en ce sens des organisations
ont un rôle capital à jouer quelles
qu'elles soient
de par les leviers d'impact qu'elles ont
sur leurs différentes communautés
clients collaborateurs partenaires
étudiants en ce sens les entrepreneurs
les gens qui pilote ces organisations
ont une capacité une opportunité d'avoir
un impact un levier d'impact et
d'irradier puisque finalement chacune
des bonnes pratiques et quelque part me
x l'ensemble des personnes qui l'
consiste et puis je reste optimiste je
pense qu'on peut et qu'on doit assumer
le courage d'entreprendre durablement
je finirai en disant que n'oublions pas
d'investir dans l'éducation puisque les
jeunes générations ont également un rôle
très important à jouer
d'ailleurs dépêchez vous de faire la
morale à vos enfants car si vous
n'adoptez pas des comportements durables
c'est probablement eux qui vous feront
la morale alors à vous de jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]